every last part of a major motion
picture is carefully planned for years
by accrued that numbers in the hundreds
the lighting has to be just right the
camera angles precisely mapped out and
the lines memorized by the actors but
sometimes magic still happens
spontaneously a last minute or
spur-of-the-moment acting choice is so
clever that it stays in the movie those
moments are often the most memorable
parts of a film we've covered some of
the most amazing unplanned cinematic
situations in our video ten spectacular
movie scenes that were improvised now
here are nine more times the actors went
off-book the Silence of the Lambs it's
already a terrifying moment in a
terrifying movie Hannibal Lecter coldly
amidst a Clarice Starling that he killed
an eighth part of a census taker he
doesn't really need to do anything
demonstrably monstrous and the script
didn't really call for it but actor
Anthony Hopkins reportedly wanted to
genuinely spook his co-star Jodie Foster
not to mention the audience so he came
up with his little snake-like hiss I ate
his liver with some fava beans and a
nice Chianti Raiders of the Lost Ark all
the fight scenes in the first Indiana
Jones movie took weeks to choreograph
including a lengthy sword versus whip
battle but when the time came to film it
Harrison Ford backed out he'd come down
with food poisoning the night before
shooting he simply couldn't go through
with the elaborate physicality of the
scene so he ran an idea past director
Steven Spielberg that became one of the
Indiana Jones series most famous moments
instead of fighting off a swordsman with
his whip in a few minutes and he just
shoots him
and a fight end of scene and Ford was
free to go
Good Will Hunting as Robin Williams
character tells a story about his
deceased wife waking herself up with her
own sleep farts mad demon can't stop
laughing he was she used to fart and
asleep
[ __ ] that one night was so loud about
the dug up the laughs are genuine
because Williams a gifted improviser
made up the whole story
both the hilarious sped about the
farting and then the really sad part
about how intimate moments like these
are what defined a happy marriage
I didn't like their man Dumb and Dumber
the script for this Farrelly Brothers
comedy called for Harry and Lloyd to get
on a hit man's nerves by arguing about
jelly beans the committee agile Jim
Carrey and theatrically trained Jeff
Daniels thought the dialogue was weak so
they tried out several ideas eventually
deciding on when you're the most
annoying sound in the world
the Godfather the scene was supposed to
be brutal but simple high-ranking
mobster Peter Clemenza played by Richard
Castellano is on his way to a hit with
an underling when his wife asked him to
pick up some cannoli as scripted
Clemenza and his stooge killed the guy
and Clemenza utters leave the gun but
when Castellano filmed the scene he
remembered the other thing is character
was supposed to do and after the hit
equipped pegged in cannoli
instructing the underling to grab the
box of cannoli on the murdered man's
dashboard delicious
Zoolander truly great moments of improv
were when they fit in perfectly within
the movie's themes case in point
Derek Zoolander asked an important
question to David Duchovny's hand model
character so why male models the company
delivers a long monologue about how male
models are involved in an assassination
plot but afterward Ben Stiller had
reportedly forgotten his next line so he
asked the same question he'd asked
moments before leading to one of the
greatest improvised responses in comedy
history but why male models serious I
just I just told you that a moment ago
right pretty woman Richard Gere's
character Edward was supposed to present
Vivian played by Julia Roberts with a
fancy necklace while filming you're
decided to prank his co-star and quickly
shut the box
Roberts was taking it back and her
laughter and surprise were so genuine
and charming that the take stay in the
movie the Warriors as the Warriors
nemesis Luther actor David Patrick Kelly
was only supposed to honestly bang a
bunch of bottles together instead he
added a little something extra
warriors come out to a schoolyard taunt
wasn't in the script but it's so
perfectly built up the drama the final
confrontation the director Walter he'll
let it stand it's now far and away the
most famous line from the 1979 cult film
aliens after a massive attack from the
aliens kills a whole bunch of humans
things look pretty bleak the line was
written as that's it what are we going
to do now
but after bill pashtun was just feeling
the vibe of private Hudson this mouthy
and eccentric character as a result he
ad-libbed the lines he'll probably be
best remembered for until the end of
time that's it man game over man game
over thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
at the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which improvised
scene was your favorite